this week special issue on food security
tackles a pretty complicated problem how
to make sure everyone in the world has
enough to eat now to understand the
basics of the food security challenge it
helps to know one number 9 billion
that's what demographers expect world
population will be in just 40 years
that's about three billion more people
than we have now and most of them will
live in poorer less developed nations in
Africa and Asia the problem is that many
of those nations are already having
trouble feeding their people sometimes
there just isn't enough food sometimes
there's enough food but people can't
afford to buy it in any case the concern
is that food insecurity will grow as the
population grows already more than two
dozen countries are facing a serious
risk of food insecurity and many of them
are the same countries in Africa and
Asia that are already having trouble
feeding their people unfortunately there
is no single solution to reducing that
risk
it will require understanding the food
implications of global markets of
international trade of human psychology
even the food traditions that determine
what we like to eat ensuring food
security will also require figuring out
how to get bigger harvests by some
estimates global yields will need to
double or even triple over the next 40
years to keep pace with population
growth in the special issue we take a
close look at how science and technology
can help farmers boost yields
particularly in the developing world we
look at efforts to improve soil
fertility even in places where farmers
might not have the money to buy
synthetic fertilizers we explore ways of
getting more crop from every drop of
water especially in dry regions we
examine new methods of speeding the
creation of better seed varieties and we
look at efforts to defend against the
pests and diseases that can devastate
harvests of course these efforts aren't
likely to blossom overnight and
researchers still need to figure out how
to increase the food supply without
seriously damaging the
environment or adding to global warming
but eventually researchers hope the
world can balance food security with
other needs and help farmers weave big
enough harvests to prevent hunger I hope
you enjoy the issue for science magazine
I'm David Malikov
you